في فرنسا ينفذ سائقون ومراقبون وعمال في
السكك الحديديه الفرنسيه اضرابا عن العمل
المطالبه بتحسين اوضاعهم ورفع اجورهم
وقالت شركه السكك الحديديه الفرنسيه ان
100000 مسافر تاثروا بسبب الاضراب عقبه
قطارين فائقي السرعه من اصل خمسه قطارات
هذا وتاخذ الحكومه الفرنسيه مفاوضات مع
النقابات للتوصلي الى حنا لالغاء الاضراب
المقرر الاسبوع المقبل والذي يتزامن مع
عوده الفرنسيه من انجازاته راس السنه
بعد الان من امام محطه قطار منبر ناس في
باريس سان مراسله الجزيره محمد البقالي
اهلا بك محمد الى اين وصلت هذه المفاوضات
حتى اللحظه
المفاوضات مستمره ولكن تاثيرها لن يكون
بالنسبه لاضراب اليوم وغدا هذه المفاوضات
هذه اضراب اليوم وغدا حزم امره وهو ماضي
المفاوضات الان تتم بشان الاضرار اضراب
الاسبوع المقبله الذي يتزامنه ايضا مع
اجازات العوده من من نهايه السنه وفي حاله
تم تنفيذه فهو ايضا سيكل ازمه في على
مستوى التنقل الفرنسيين همم النقابات
اختارت في الحقيقه توقيت دقيقه وحارجا وهو
توقيت اعياد الميلاد وايضا توقيت العوده
من انجازات نهايه همم السنه والنتيجه وهي
ما ترون همم حوالي 40% من القطارات
الفائقه للسرعه تم الغاءها والواقع انه
كان يمكن ان تكون المشاهد اكبر بكثير من
هذا الذي نراه لولا انه تم الاعلان عن
الاضرار مبكرا وبالتالي فان معظم
المسافرين اتخذوا احتياطاتهم من خلال
البحث عن وسائل العقل اخرى بديله سواء عن
طريق الحافلات او عن طريق السيارات
المشتركه او غير همم ذلك لكن بشكل عام هذا
لاضراف في الحقيقه يمكن ان نقول انه يعطي
فكره عما ينتظر فرنسا هذه السنه من
احتجاجات وغضب جماعي واجتماعي
لانقطع النقل قطاع الصحه قطعه تعليم
وغيرها من القطاعات كلها تتواعد بانها
لديها مطالب وانها لم تتحقق وانها ستدخل
ايضا في موجه اضرابات هذا بالاضافه الى ان
الحكومه لديها مشروع قوانين لا تثير حولها
الاجماع مثل مشروع قانون التقاعد وهذا
يعني ان السنه تكون ساخنه على المستوى
الاجتماعي والسياسي هذا الاضراب ايضا طرح
اشكال فيما يتعلق
باستلهام التجربه الايطاليه كما قيل هنا
في فرنسا لماذا لانه في ايطاليا يمنع
الاضراب في بعض الايام المحدده في السنه
مثلا ايام الميلاد في قطاع النقل كي لا
يتسبب ذلك في المسجد بحق المواطن في
الخدمه العموميه هناك نقاش في فرنسا بهذا
الشان ولكن يبدو من الصعب جدا تطبيق هذا
الامر في فرنسا بالنظر الى قوه النقابات
وقوه الحركه الاحتجاجيه علامه على هذا
الامر طرح ايضا نقاش اخر بشان احتكار
النقابات كما هو معلوم للعمل النقابي
والاحتجاج لان النتيجه على هذا الاضراب
يصل الى هذه الدرجه ويكون تاثيره همم
كبيرا ليست فقط ان نقبات الداعيه اليه
ولكن ايضا المجموعات التي تشكلت على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي والتي لا تندرج ولا
تنخرط ضمن اي نقابه وهناك تخوف لدى
الحكومه او ايضا لدى النقابات من ان العمل
النقابي وقرارات كبيره تؤثر على حياه
الناس قد تخرج من يده النقابات ليتم همم
والتوافق بشانها في وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي وهذا يذكر الحكومه بذكرى سيئه
وهي ذكرى السترات الصفراء التي كانت اكبر
حركه احتجاجيه تعرفها فرنسا تقريبا منذ
عام 1963 شكرا جزيلا لك من باريس الجزيره
محمد البقالي